il est 17h30 hier les barrières se
baissent les feux clignotent pour
signaler l'arrivée du train un véhicule
se retrouve alors soudainement bloqué
sur les rails selon les témoignages
d'automobilistes les feux du véhicule
s'allume puis s'éteignent à plusieurs
reprises ce qui laisse à penser que la
personne au volant tente de redémarrer
le véhicule
en vain quelques secondes plus tard la
voiture et percuté par un ter circulant
dans le sens auxerre paris cet habitant
vite à proximité du passage à niveau
il témoigne de la violence du choc est
attendu un grand boum h sortie balle
c'est le train que rentrer dans une
voiture ils ont mené à deux ou trois
cents mètres plus bas
oui s'il n'y avait plus rien des débris
c'est tout mais autrement y avait plus
rien à voir ici
côté partis d'abord à bord du véhicule
se trouve une mère et son fils tous deux
des sept dans l'accident le garçon âgé
de 19 ans étaient scolarisés à l'iut
d'auxerre
la maman âgée de 49 ans vivait dans le
petit village de trancault situé dans
l'aube
dès hier soir le parquet d'auxerre
décide d'ouvrir une enquête pour tenter
de connaître les circonstances de
l'accident
plusieurs constatations sont effectués
dans la nuit puis ce matin par la police
scientifique
plusieurs témoins directs ou indirects
ont été auditionnés ce matin au
commissariat pour tenter de faire la
lumière sur cet accident les enquêteurs
comptent surtout sur les photos prises
par ce radar situé à proximité du
passage à niveau
l'enquêté tentera de déterminer pourquoi
la voiture s'est retrouvée entre les
deux barrières de sécurité et qui se
trouvait au volant du véhicule
de son côté la sncf n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer avant la communication
officielle des résultats de l' enquête
le procureur de la république vient tout
juste de s'exprimer selon les derniers
éléments de l'enquète c'est bien la mère
qui se trouvait au volant du véhicule le
fils se trouvait sur le siège du
passager avant
élément important il n'y a pas eu de non
respect du feu rouge puisque le véhicule
n'a pas fait déclencher le radar alors
selon des témoignages recueillis ce
matin il ya bien eu un signal sonore des
barrières se sont abaissées pour
annoncer l'arrivée du train la question
c'est de savoir pourquoi le véhicule est
resté coincé entre les deux barrières de
sécurité la maman at-elle été distraite
par une conversation téléphonique que
son fils avait avec sa copine juste
avant le moment de l'accident at elle
ralentit dans le virage
les investigations vont donc se
poursuivre une autopsie sera réalisée
sur les corps demain matin